[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here
welcome back to quarantine content just
a little bit entertainment for you while
we're all staying inside
I'm your host marques Brownlee coming at
you from a slightly dish of old slowly
deconstructing Studio a as we of course
move to our new space and this is what's
on my phone twenty twenty so this has
somehow stayed at like the top of the
the most requested list of what you guys
want to see in the comments section no
matter what's going on people always
asking hey where's the Twenty twenty
version so I'm going to show you guys
what's on my phone but with a little bit
of a twist so I have showed the layout
like the apps what's on my phone before
last year the year before I'll link
those videos below the like button if
you want to see them check them out
again this year my setup is again as you
can see pretty similar to those see here
you go to page setup again same general
layout of the apps I mean I have slack
on here now instead of group me and
maybe one or two other apps are
different but for the most part you can
see what's going on it's very similar to
before but the plot twist I guess that
you can see is the phone I'm using on
the daily right now is the samsung
galaxy s 20 ultra as you can see for now
I mean we both already know there's a
ton of phones on the horizon and I don't
typically stay with one phone for too
long as a phone reviewer but this is
further from the typical standard Google
experience that I usually use as my
daily driver you might be used to me
having a pixel or one plus phone in
these videos so I figured I would show
you guys some tweaks some things that I
do to make this phone feel a little bit
more stock or at least behave more like
the way I prefer it to that usually is
default in stock phones and just
generally the way as I sit to make in my
own so that's what i'ma show and before
you even ask yes the wallpaper is first
link with a like button if you want to
check it out you don't have to ask for
that in the comments you're welcome
let's get into it okay so with galaxy s
20 ultra first thing of course I did was
switch to 120 Hertz
you might recall it's set to 1080p 60
Hertz out the box that's in settings and
display settings and motionsmoothness
you happen to not be able to switch to
14
EP at this high refresh rate as you're
probably already aware but I'll take
under 20 Hertz over a barely perceivable
increase in pixels per inch any day but
then the second thing I've enabled is
gesture navigation it's the normal
Android button layout at the bottom
out-of-the-box but I am fully used to
the gestures everywhere now and this is
also time to be grateful for searchable
settings by the way you don't have to
memorize which category which section
everything you want to look for is in
you just hit the search box type in
pretty much exactly what you're looking
for and it comes up so I still use the
default launcher with Samsung because
you can't as of right now use the
gestures with a third-party launcher
like Nova Launcher I believe that's an
update that's pretty shortly coming and
I love Nova Launcher but Samsung's
launcher for now is pretty workable
first of all I always go into home
screen settings with a long press and
change a few things in here I always
change the homescreen grid size to five
by five across instead of the default
four which looks a little bit cartoony
and then in that same setting I turn on
swipe down for notification panel so I
can always swipe down into my
notifications from anywhere instead of
having to reach all the way up at the
top big phones require big phone
solutions so without having big hands
you can always get two notifications and
then I always disable Samsung daily
that's screened to the left of the home
screen that's on by default I never use
it and then in the app drawer I sort by
alphabetical which is what literally
every other app drawer does by default
except for Samsung's and then that is
pretty much it for my home screen
behavior so now it's working closer to
the way I want it but there's still a
good amount of stuff to do for a Samsung
phone number one default apps and
Samsung is not the only one who's guilty
of putting their own versions of apps on
their phones but there's always a couple
things that I change that I use more
often than the first-party alternative
so I'm always switching out google
chrome to be my default browser and I'm
always grabbing the messaging app by
Google that's always my default texting
app on any Android phone and I also set
G board the Google keyboard to be my
default keyboard on every single phone
no matter what also for those curious I
use Spotify for like 99% of my music
listening but I use pocket casts for
podcasts even though I could do that and
Spotify just because there's more
features and pocket casts and then Bixby
we got to get rid of the last little bit
of traces of Bixby so by default long
pressing the power button will open
Bixby so if you go into the settings and
search for side key you can then set the
double press of the power button to be
whatever you want
typically camera is easiest to remember
and then press and hold doesn't trigger
Bixby you can just have it trigger the
turning off the phone menu I guess that
is the beauty of Android is they might
put stuffing your way there might be
bloatware but you can disable it you can
remove things you can switch them up to
actually be the way you want so that's
the last of Bixby then I go into the
quick settings and just clean up those
top quick settings to be just the ones I
use the most often and then I honestly
get rid of the ones I never used because
on the off chance I ever actually do
need them
I can always search in the settings to
find them pretty easily so those are the
quick settings that I used obviously
Wi-Fi is up there and I do use
flashlight a lot and then in that same
menu there's a quick panel layout which
lets you show brightness on top and then
you can uncheck show media and devices
and so now every time you swipe down
from the top brightness is always up
there which it wasn't before and then
now with a couple phones there's just so
much RAM that you can there's a feature
that I'll let you pin apps permanently
in the RAM the Samsung phone is one of
them so I do pin my tasks app which is
tick tick in my RAM permanently I kind
of experimented a bit with also pinning
Spotify in there but I found I don't use
Spotify that much and it opens pretty
quickly and it streams in the background
fine so just my tasks app is always in
the background and then there's a couple
other small things that I would call
like pro tips they are from an Android
police article that I shared not too
long ago but I'll leave it down below as
well these are more advanced but they
are a little tweaks that just work
better when they're enabled in my
opinion so number one is use volume keys
for media by default the volume piece
switch your ringer volume so if no
volume is playing I just want them to be
purely media volume keys so hit the
volume button swipe down tap volume keys
from media and there you go and then
also you can turn on show battery
percentage in status bar all the time
and Beauty again of searchable settings
as you go into the settings and you
literally just search show percent
and it already knows you want to show %
in status bar for the battery so that's
how you turn that on and I don't know
exactly how much better you have left
and then the last one really good one
how specifically to do with Google
photos so I use Google photos as my
default backup app for all photos and
videos that I take on my phones they go
straight to the cloud and then I can
look at them on a bigger screen but to
make sure they always upload as soon as
you take the photo instead of hours
later there's a power optimization trick
so the advice define this is to go into
settings and search for optimized
battery usage then click into that then
click at the top optimize battery usage
then switch to viewing all apps then
search for photos and when you get the
Photos app deselect it and so now that
it's out of that power optimization it
will use as much power as it needs to to
keep you firmly up to date and always
upload your photos right as soon as you
take them so there you have it if you do
all of these things you're now running
your Samsung phone just like my Samsung
phone of course there's a bunch of tips
that you can pick up for your own setup
and I will say if you have your own
setup tricks leave those in the comments
section below I'll heart some my
favorite ones that can also give a
better more optimized experience and
really I don't have to do all this work
for every phone I use with some there's
way less and the defaults are typically
how I like them with some others there's
a lot more work to do some phones fall
somewhere in the middle but generally
that's now you've seen what's on my
phone and what I do to set it up the way
I want and that's about it hopefully you
enjoyed thanks for watching catch you
guys in the next one peace